A ver, te fracturas un hueso, miras la radiografía y, bueno, el
problema está ahí, o sea, en blanco y negro.
Totalmente. Es la línea dentada brillante en la placa, ¿no?
Exacto. El diagnóstico es irrefutable y el plan de acción, pues, es bastante obvio.
Es un mundo binario, súper limpio y reconfortante.
Pero la clínica real rara vez es así de limpia.
Para nada. Imaginen, a quienes nos escuchan, que entran a la
consulta y se encuentran con una paciente exhausta, ardiendo en fiebre.
Y tu mejor herramienta ahí no es una máquina de millones de dólares, sino
saber exactamente qué parte del cuello tocar.
Sí, de pronto toda esa precisión radiológica desaparece.
Y nos sumergimos de lleno en las aguas más turbias del diagnóstico clínico.
Es una excelente forma de describirlo, la verdad.
Porque esas aguas diagnósticas son precisamente el lugar donde la intuición por
sí sola,
sin importar los años de experiencia clínica que se tengan, te puede traicionar.
Sí, te traiciona hasta al médico más astuto.
Exactamente. Sin una brújula basada en la evidencia, navegar por los síntomas
y los signos es, digamos, como caminar a ciegas.
Y el objetivo de esta inmersión profunda de hoy, de este análisis de
medsemiotics, es armar esa brújula.
Así que, bienvenidos y bienvenidas.
Es un gusto estar aquí para desglosar esto.
Para quienes están escuchando, es importante aclarar cómo vamos a proceder en esta
sesión. No vamos a leer un resumen plano de un texto.
No, eso no tendría sentido.
O sea, tenemos sobre la mesa un caso clínico socrático real sobre la mononucleosis
infecciosa.
Y vamos a usar una dinámica muy particular, ¿verdad?
Así es. Plantearemos un escenario o una encrucijada clínica y
haremos una pequeña pausa.
Exacto. Una pausa para que cada quien en su cabeza formule su propia respuesta.
Y luego desglosaremos la lógica bayesiana detrás de cada paso.
Queremos explorar cómo los hallazgos alteran la probabilidad de un diagnóstico.
O cómo, a veces de forma súper contraintuitiva, no la
alteran en absoluto.
Es un ejercicio puro de calibración mental.
Así que, bueno, sin más preámbulos, pongamos el caso sobre la mesa.
¿Te parece?
Me parece perfecto. Vamos con los datos.
Listo. Tenemos a una mujer de 19 años, estudiante
universitaria, que además vive en una residencia.
Un dato demográfico y epidemiológico clave, desde ya.
Totalmente. Sus motivos de consulta principales son, a ver,
odinofagia de 10 días de evolución, fiebre diaria de predominio
vespertino y una astenia tan brutal que literalmente la
postra.
O sea, no es solo cansancio.
La tiene en cama.
Así es. De hecho, ha dejado de asistir a clases.
Además, come muy poco porque el dolor al tragar es insoportable.
Y tenemos datos negativos importantes.
No hay tos, no hay rinorrea, ni disnea.
Bien, y asumo que no ha tomado nada.
Exacto. Otro dato crucial es que no ha tomado antibióticos.
Como antecedente, comenta que una compañera de habitación tuvo un cuadro muy
parecido el mes pasado.
El clásico escenario de atención primaria, digamos.
Sí, la típica paciente que te llega un viernes por la tarde a la consulta.
En la exploración inicial, sus signos vitales están estables.
Tiene una frecuencia cardíaca de 96 latidos por minuto y una temperatura de
38.2 grados Celsius.
Perfecto. Un cuadro muy representativo.
Entonces, aquí viene la primera pregunta para reflexionar.
Considerando este cuadro, ¿qué diagnósticos explican un dolor de garganta con
fiebre y cansancio tan prolongado a esta edad?
Y sobre todo, ¿con qué probabilidad de partida matemática trabajamos antes de
siquiera tocar a la paciente?
Demos un segundito para que quienes escuchan armen su diferencial en la mente.
Sí, piénsenlo bien.
Fiebre, odinofagia y astenia en una joven de 19.
Yo la verdad pensaría en varias opciones de entrada.
Claro. El diagnóstico diferencial razonable y obligatorio aquí
incluye, por supuesto, una faringitis viral inespecífica, la faringitis
estreptocócica, la mononucleosis infecciosa, infección por
citomegalovirus, toxoplasmosis y…
Y algo que jamás, pero jamás se debe omitir.
Exacto. La infección aguda por el virus de la inmunodeficiencia humana.
Es que todos estos patógenos pueden simular un cuadro muy similar en su fase
inicial.
Así es. Sin embargo, hay una clave narrativa en lo que nos
cuenta la paciente que, o sea, aleja significativamente al estreptococo de la lista
de sospechosos principales.
Te refieres a los 10 días de duración de los síntomas, ¿no?
Exactamente eso. Una faringitis bacteriana aguda rara vez produce
10 días de postración absoluta sin evolucionar hacia una complicación
supurativa evidente o resolverse por sí sola.
Claro, el curso temporal mismo nos empuja hacia las otras etiologías.
Pero a ver, antes de empezar a sumar síntomas o a buscar ganglios, el
razonamiento bayesiano nos exige un ancla numérica.
El famoso punto de partida.
Exacto. No podemos simplemente decir en la nota sospecho
mononucleosis porque me late.
Necesitamos un suelo firme.
Y ese suelo es el concepto vital de la probabilidad basal.
¿Cuál sería el número exacto aquí?
Pues antes de realizar cualquier maniobra de exploración física, la probabilidad de
partida documentada en la base de medsemiotics para pacientes de 16 a 20 años
que consultan primariamente por odinofagia es de 0.077.
O sea, estamos hablando de un 7.7%.
Exactamente, un 7.7%.
Para visualizarlo bien, digamos que de cada 100 pacientes de esa edad que
entran por la puerta quejándose de dolor de garganta, casi 8 tendrán
mononucleosis antes de que hagamos una sola pregunta más.
Ese 0.077 es el cimiento de todo.
Sin ese número, cualquier cociente de verosimilitud, cualquier LR
que calculemos después, flotaría en el vacío.
No tendría nada que multiplicar.
Tal cual. Y sabiendo esto, podemos entrar al primer movimiento del razonamiento
clínico de hoy, la trampa de la anamnesis, es decir, lo que nos
cuenta la paciente.
Y aquí es donde la intuición suele fallar estrepitosamente, la verdad.
Nuestra paciente nos relata odinofagia y astenia muy marcadas.
Sí, síntomas gravosos para ella.
Y si revisamos la evidencia, ambos síntomas tienen una sensibilidad de 0.81.
Lo cual es altísimo.
Significa que están presentes en la inmensa mayoría de los pacientes que realmente
padecen mononucleosis.
Así que planteemos la segunda pregunta socrática.
Si estos síntomas están en más del 80% de los enfermos,
¿cuánto aumentan la probabilidad de que esta paciente en particular tenga el
cuadro?
Quienes nos escuchan, piensen un número.
¿Cuánto sube desde ese 7.7%?
Sí, hagan su apuesta mental.
Cuando leí la base de datos sobre esto, te prometo que me quedé
pensando un buen rato, porque la respuesta desafía el
instinto básico del médico.
Totalmente. Porque aumentan la probabilidad en exactamente cero.
Cero. O sea, absolutamente nada.
Nada de nada. La base de evidencia declara formalmente que estos síntomas son
sin efecto discriminativo.
No vas a encontrar un LR positivo medido o publicado para ellos.
Y la razón es la diferencia fundamental entre la sensibilidad y la
especificidad.
Claro, son síntomas altísimamente sensibles.
Casi todo el que tiene mononucleosis, pues, tiene dolor de garganta y está cansado.
Pero son totalmente inespecíficos frente a las decenas de otras causas de
odinofagia.
O sea, si todo el mundo en la sala de espera de urgencias tiene dolor de garganta,
ese síntoma no te ayuda a distinguir quién tiene el virus de Epstein-Barr y quién
tiene un simple rinovirus.
Entiendo la estadística, claro.
Claro, pero si no discriminan, a ver, si mi aguja no se mueve ni un
milímetro de ese 0.077 inicial, me surge
una duda genuina.
Dime.
¿Para qué perdemos valiosos minutos en la consulta detallando estos síntomas si
matemáticamente no nos acercan al diagnóstico?
Es un cuestionamiento brillante porque revela por qué la medicina no es
solo matemáticas.
Hay tres motivos fundamentales por los que este interrogatorio no es ninguna
pérdida de tiempo.
A ver, ilúminame.
Primero, porque definen la población pre-test.
Ah, claro, las reglas del juego.
Exacto. Esos síntomas son los que nos permiten usar el famoso 0.077.
Extrapolar los cocientes de verosimilitud de la mononucleosis a alguien que,
digamos, consulta por un dolor de rodilla y no tiene odinofagia sería un error
metodológico garrafal.
Lógico. Tienes que estar en la cancha correcta para usar las estadísticas
correctas. ¿Y el segundo motivo?
Segundo, porque fijan el curso temporal.
Ya mencionamos que los 10 días de astenia son los que alejan drásticamente la causa
bacteriana aguda.
El tiempo nos da el contexto.
Y tercero, y quizá lo más importante para la paciente humana que tienes enfrente,
es que guían el manejo de soporte.
Claro, si no exploramos la intensidad de la odinofagia, no sabremos que ha dejado
de comer,
o que quizá necesite analgesia pautada o hidratación intravenosa.
Así es, el diagnóstico es un medio, pero aliviar es el fin último.
Bien, queda clarísimo el valor narrativo, aunque el valor diagnóstico
numérico sea nulo. Así que, ya que lo que la paciente nos cuenta no
confirma el cuadro por sí solo, tenemos que depender de lo que las manos y los ojos
buscan deliberadamente.
Pasamos a la exploración física.
Exacto, el segundo movimiento, el mapa del cuello y el valor clínico de la
ausencia.
En la exploración, palpamos adenopatías generalizadas.
Un dato muy revelador.
Encontramos ganglios móviles y dolorosos de unos 0.5 centímetros en la cadena
cervical posterior bilateral.
Y ojo, también en axilas y en ingles.
Además, al iluminar la boca, la faringe está eritematosa y tiene exudado.
Básicamente, es un cuello que te está gritando inflamación linfoide.
Totalmente. Pero juguemos con un escenario alternativo para los que escuchan.
Imaginen que hacemos esta misma exploración minuciosa en el cuello, en las axilas,
y no palpamos absolutamente ningún ganglio.
Ok, el escenario opuesto.
¿Qué haríamos con nuestra sospecha de mononucleosis en ese caso?
Tómense un momento para pensarlo.
Es una pregunta excelente.
Porque hay un dicho en medicina, ¿no?
Eso de que la ausencia de evidencia no es evidencia de ausencia.
Pero aquí, no encontrar ganglios es oro puro, ¿verdad?
Aquí rompe la regla. Es el único hallazgo en la exploración que casi,
casi permite descartar el cuadro por completo.
¿Tan potente es?
Sí, la sensibilidad de las adenopatías es de 0.91.
Si no están, la probabilidad simplemente se desploma.
La base de datos nos dice que el LR negativo para la ausencia de ganglios cae en un
rango de entre 0.23 y 0.44.
A ver, detengámonos ahí un segundo.
Entre 0.23 y 0.44.
Ese es un rango bastante amplio.
No es un número limpio que puedas meter fácil en una fórmula o en una app.
Y es una distinción crítica que hay que entender.
Ese intervalo es un rango entre estudios.
Significa que diferentes investigaciones de alta calidad encontraron valores
distintos, pero todos dentro de ese espectro.
O sea, no es una estimación puntual precisa.
Exacto. Es el dato que más empuja la probabilidad basal hacia abajo de todos, pero
precisamente por la amplitud de este rango metodológico, no te permite cerrar la
puerta del caso al 100%. Reduce muchísimo la sospecha, pero siempre, siempre queda
un resquicio.
Bueno, afortunadamente, nuestra paciente de hoy sí tiene ganglios.
Palpamos adenopatías posteriores, axilares e inguinales.
Así que, pensemos ahora en la topografía.
La anatomía es clave aquí.
Y esta es la siguiente pausa socrática.
¿Cuánto aporta cada localización específica?
¿Y por qué distinguir entre la cadena cervical anterior y posterior?
No es solo una pedantería anatómica.
Dele una vuelta a la fisiopatología.
Yo siempre he pensado que explorar el cuello en busca de ganglios
Es, digamos, como seguir el cauce de un río hasta su
origen. Cada afluente te cuenta una historia sobre de dónde viene el agua.
Esa analogía me encanta, porque captura perfectamente la fisiopatología del
proceso.
A ver, el virus de Epstein-Barr tiene predilección por replicarse inicialmente en
el epitelio y el tejido linfoide de la nasofaringe.
Y si entiendes la anatomía del drenaje linfático de esa zona, sabes que la
linfa de la nasofaringe viaja directamente hacia la cadena cervical posterior.
Por eso el origen de ese río importa tanto.
Mientras que, por ejemplo, una amigdalitis bacteriana clásica drena de forma
diferente, ¿no?
Correcto. Una adenopatía anterior hipertrófica apunta mucho más a una
faringitis estreptocócica.
En cambio, encontrar una adenopatía posterior te da un LR positivo de 3.1.
Nada mal.
Sí, con un intervalo de confianza del 95% que va de 1.6 a
5.9 y una especificidad de 0.87.
El cauce te lleva directo al virus.
Y no olvidemos el territorio sistémico de nuestra paciente.
Porque palpar ganglios en la ingle o en la axila, la base nos dice que tiene un
LR positivo que también ronda el rango de 3.0 a 3.1.
Claro, empujan la probabilidad hacia la mononucleosis porque evidencian que el
virus ya no está solo ahí en la garganta, sino que se ha diseminado en todo el
sistema retículo endotelial.
Pero, a ver, la base de datos lanza una advertencia sobre esto.
Hay que tener mucho cuidado con lo que consideramos un ganglio.
Uf, los falsos positivos.
Son el pan de cada día.
Sí.
Si un clínico inexperto confunde una masa muscular del
esternocleidomastoideo con un ganglio cervical posterior
o palpa la glándula submandibular creyendo que es tejido linfoide,
pues todo ese LR de 3.1 desaparece.
Es que la calculadora bayesiana no puede corregir unas manos mal entrenadas.
Si metes datos basura en la ecuación, no tienes probabilidades basura.
Así de simple.
Lo cual nos lleva a expandir nuestra búsqueda en el tercer movimiento,
el paladar, el vazo, y cómo lidiamos con la
incertidumbre en la vida real.
Vamos allá.
El cuello ya nos dio pistas sólidas con sus LR de 3.1, pero
un clínico metódico sabe que hay dos lugares más que no se pueden ignorar de
ninguna manera.
¿Qué buscamos ahora?
Con una muy buena fuente de luz, revisamos la boca de la paciente
y observamos petequias justo en la unión del paladar duro y blando.
Un signo clásico.
Y luego la acostamos en decúbito lateral derecho, percutimos y
notamos matidez en el espacio de Traube.
Logramos palpar el polo del vazo.
Hay esplenomegalia clara.
Hallazgos semiológicos de libro, pero con un impacto probabilístico muy
distinto entre sí.
Aquí va la interrogante para quienes están visualizando el caso con nosotros.
De todo lo explorado hasta ahora, si tuvieran que apostar por un solo
hallazgo, ¿cuál es el que desplaza más violentamente la probabilidad a favor del
diagnóstico, superando incluso a los ganglios del cuello?
Unos segundos para que decidan. ¿Las petequias o el vazo palpable?
Uno podría pensar que el vazo, ¿no?
Por ser un órgano interno grande.
Parece la prueba reina de la mononucleosis.
Pero no es así.
¿Sí?
Sorprendentemente no lo es.
Son las petequias en el paladar.
Las petequias.
Sí.
La fuerza diagnóstica de esas pequeñas hemorragias puntiformes es
colosal.
Presentan un LR positivo de 5.3.
¡Guau!
Y fíjate, con un intervalo de confianza del 95% que va de 2.1 a 13 y
una especificidad brutal de 0.95.
Un LR de 5.3 es un salto inmenso si lo comparas con el 3.1
que nos daba el cuello.
Y, fisiopatológicamente, ¿por qué salen?
Estas petequias ocurren por la invasión viral local y una fragilidad vascular
transitoria.
Y cuando las ves justo ahí, en esa frontera anatómica entre el paladar duro y el
blando, la probabilidad se dispara.
Ahora, hay algo en la evidencia de medsemiotics que resulta fascinante desde el
punto de vista del método.
La base registra mediciones distintas para las petequias y para la
esplenomegalia, pero las presenta en forma de rangos.
Por ejemplo, nos dice que el LR positivo de las petequias oscila entre 1.32
y 11.4, según el estudio.
Y para el vazo, el LR positivo va de 1.9 a 6.6.
Números súper amplios.
Exacto. Entonces, la pregunta clave aquí es, ¿qué significa esta discrepancia
metodológica y cómo demonios debe manejarla el clínico frente a la paciente?
Piénsenlo, porque es un reto interpretar rangos tan grandes en la práctica.
Es que a los médicos, y la verdad yo me incluyo, nos encantan los algoritmos
súper limpios. Queremos una cifra exacta, un número cerrado, para poder
calcular el riesgo final de manera pulcra.
Pero la biología humana se resiste a esa pulcritud.
Ver un rango entre estudios o un LR declarado como no
medible de forma puntual, en la base, es un fracaso de la literatura
médica.
No.
No, es la comunicación más honesta posible de la incertidumbre clínica que existe.
Tomemos la esplenomegalia como ejemplo perfecto.
La capacidad de palpar un vazo no es una constante universal, digamos.
Depende de muchísimas cosas.
Depende de la pericia táctil del médico que explora, depende del hábito
constitucional de la paciente. O sea, no es lo mismo explorar un abdomen excavado
que uno con gran panículo adiposo.
Y depende de la maniobra en sí.
Buscar la matidez en el espacio de Traube, esa zona delimitada por la sexta
costilla y el reborde costal izquierdo, requiere una técnica muy depurada.
Totalmente.
O realizar la maniobra de Middleton, donde haces que el paciente coloque su
antebrazo bajo la parrilla costal para empujar el vazo hacia adelante, mientras
el clínico intenta enganchar el polo esplénico durante la inspiración profunda.
Todo eso introduce muchísima variabilidad en los estudios.
Exacto. El rendimiento de la prueba fluctúa salvajemente dependiendo de quién la
haga y a quién se la haga. Por eso el LR reportado va de 1.9 a 6.6.
Y eso nos lleva a un giro interesantísimo en el manejo de este caso.
A ver.
Sabemos que el vazo palpable tiene esta enorme variabilidad, sí, y que
matemáticamente discrimina menos que las petequias.
Claro.
Sin embargo, la pregunta para la audiencia es, ¿por qué este hallazgo
específico del vazo cambia hoy mismo, antes de que salga de la consulta, la
instrucción clínica que le daremos a la paciente?
Un par de segundos para que quienes escuchan lo razonen.
¿Por qué el vazo cambia todo hoy?
Porque de pronto el diagnóstico en sí pasa a un segundo plano.
Pasa a ser un tema de urgencia.
Totalmente. Deja de ser un dato puramente diagnóstico para calcular LRs y se
convierte en una intervención de seguridad imperativa.
Palpar ese vazo significa que el órgano está congestivo, está inflamado y es muy
friable.
Lo cual condiciona directamente el consejo médico.
Exige prohibir cualquier deporte de contacto.
Sí. Un trauma abdominal, por menor que le parezca a la paciente, tiene un riesgo
catastrófico de provocar una rotura esplénica.
Y eso es una emergencia quirúrgica letal.
Pasamos de la semiología fina y estadística a evitar una verdadera tragedia.
Así es.
Bien, recapitulemos.
Tenemos ganglios posteriores, tenemos petequias y documentamos
esplenomegalia. Es momento de avanzar al cuarto movimiento, el
frotis sanguíneo y la peligrosa trampa de la calculadora bayesiana.
Ah, la prueba complementaria clave.
Solicitamos un hemograma. Los resultados muestran leucocitos en 12.8
por 10 a la 9 por litro, con un 62% de predominio
linfocitario. Pero el dato de oro que estábamos buscando.
Un 18% de linfocitos atípicos.
Esas células inmensas.
Sí, con un citoplasma que parece fluir alrededor de
los glóbulos rojos y un núcleo de forma totalmente irregular.
Están respondiendo agresivamente al virus.
Las famosas células de Downey, el sello microscópico de esta guerra
inmunológica.
Entonces, con este 18% en mente, la duda es, ¿cuánto
empuja este hallazgo la balanza de la probabilidad?
¿Y qué pasaría si este porcentaje fuera drásticamente mayor?
Quienes nos escuchan visualizan el impacto de los linfocitos atípicos.
Es el momento de la verdad diagnóstica.
Llegamos al peso pesado de las pruebas, sin duda.
Sin lugar a dudas.
La linfocitosis atípica es el rey indiscutible en este escenario de
mononucleosis.
Y lo que el clínico debe saber es que su poder diagnóstico funciona mediante
umbrales acumulativos.
O sea, no es solo los tiene o no los tiene.
Exacto. No es un binario de presente o ausente.
Con un 18%, la paciente ha superado el primer gran umbral,
que es tener mayor o igual al 10% de linfocitos atípicos.
Solo superar ese umbral del 10% ya nos otorga un
LR positivo de 11.4.
Wow. Para ponerlo en perspectiva, un LR de 11.4
no es, digamos, solo una pista sutil.
Es prácticamente un letrero de neón gigante apuntando al diagnóstico.
No es. Pero observa la escala, porque se pone más extremo.
Si el frotis hubiera reportado un porcentaje mayor o igual al 20%,
el LR positivo saltaría a 26.
Increíble.
Y si la proliferación fuera tan masiva que superara el 40%,
tendríamos un LR positivo de 50, un número casi
definitivo en medicina clínica.
Ahora, hay un detalle técnico en la base que me llama muchísimo la atención.
Nuestra paciente también cumple lo que llaman el criterio combinado.
Ah, sí, el criterio combinado de porcentaje.
Porque tiene más del 50% de linfocitos totales y, a la vez,
más del 10% de linfocitos atípicos.
El documento menciona que este criterio combinado otorga un LR positivo
monumental de 54.
Es un número enorme.
Claro. Y con ese número, uno pensaría que el caso está cerrado de golpe y no hay
más que hablar.
Es una tentación muy grande, pero aquí es donde se exige una cautela clínica
absoluta.
¿Por el intervalo?
Sí. Sí. El LR puntual es de 54.
Pero si miramos de cerca el intervalo de confianza del 95% para ese criterio
combinado, en los estudios, vemos que es masivo.
Va desde 8.4 hasta 189.
Imagínate, un intervalo de 8.4 a 189 es el equivalente
estadístico de decir el objeto mide entre un centímetro y dos kilómetros.
Es una barbaridad metodológica, totalmente.
Por eso mismo, el médico prudente debe fijarse siempre en el límite inferior
de ese intervalo para no sobre reaccionar ante el número puntual.
O sea, quedarnos con el 8.4.
Exacto. En el escenario más pesimista, la fuerza real de la prueba podría ser solo
de 8.4, que sigue siendo una evidencia muy robusta.
Pero está lejos de ese espejismo mágico del 54.
Y esto nos sirve de preludio perfecto para el error que todo clínico, armado con
una de estas apps de cálculo bayesiano en su teléfono, ha estado tentado a cometer
alguna vez en la guardia.
Vamos con el error bayesiano.
Tenemos adenopatías cervicales posteriores, tenemos las petequias palatinas,
documentamos esplenomegalia y ahora poseemos esta linfocitosis
atípica contundente.
La pregunta bayesiana definitiva para la audiencia es, ¿podemos simplemente
multiplicar todos estos LRs entre sí en nuestra calculadora para obtener la
probabilidad final irrefutable?
Piénsenlo antes de responder mentalmente.
¿Multiplican el 3.1 por el 5.3 por el 11.4?
La matemática pura intuitivamente sugeriría que sí, ¿verdad?
Si tengo cuatro pruebas positivas con LRs altos, pues los multiplico y
obtengo una certeza del 99.9%.
¿Por qué no hacerlo?
Porque es un error conceptual gigantesco.
Y la palabra clave en lo que acabas de decir es pruebas independientes.
Ah, claro.
Multiplicar cocientes de verosimilitud asume estrictamente que los hallazgos no
tienen ninguna relación causal entre sí.
Pero en esta paciente no estamos frente a variables aisladas.
Las adenopatías, el vazo y los linfocitos atípicos.
Son todos consecuencia directa de exactamente la misma tormenta fisiopatológica.
La proliferación del tejido linfoide generada por el sistema inmune
contra el virus de Epstein-Barr.
Así es. Son distintas manifestaciones anatómicas del mismo
fenómeno celular sistémico.
Claro. Si los encadenamos matemáticamente y multiplicamos estos LRs,
estaremos inflando artificialmente nuestra certeza.
Contando el mismo fenómeno fisiológico tres o cuatro veces, básicamente.
Lo que dicta la prudencia metodológica, entonces, es tomar el hallazgo
más potente y objetivo, que en este caso es el frotis sanguíneo, aplicar
su LR a nuestra probabilidad basal del 0.077 y
luego evaluar cualitativamente si el resto de los signos clínicos, como
el vazo y los ganglios, sostienen y son coherentes con esa conclusión.
Exactamente. Así se hace la medicina basada en evidencia sin caer en
trampas matemáticas.
Lo cual nos lleva a la conclusión y al manejo en la vida real.
La probabilidad de que estemos ante una mononucleosis infecciosa ya es
abrumadoramente alta.
Estamos frente a la paciente ahora mismo.
Y ella nos lanza dos preguntas muy directas.
¿Puedo volver a entrenar baloncesto la próxima semana?
¿Y me recetará un antibiótico fuerte para que por fin se me quite este dolor
de garganta?
Dos preguntas súper comunes.
Reflexionemos.
¿Qué se le responde basándonos estrictamente en la evidencia?
Y además, ¿tiene sentido a estas alturas pedir una serología
confirmatoria?
Demos unos segundos para pensar en ese plan de acción.
Es el momento de la verdad en la consulta, ¿no?
Donde todos estos números y probabilidades se transforman en indicaciones
reales.
La evidencia dicta una conducta inequívoca aquí.
Cero antibióticos.
El uso empírico de aminopenicilinas en este escenario específico no solo es inútil
contra un virus.
Sino que añade un riesgo enorme de daño iatrogénico.
Provocará de forma casi segura un exantema generalizado maculopapilar en la
paciente.
Y ojo para los que escuchan, esto no es una verdadera alergia mediada
por IgE.
Es una reacción transitoria mediada por inmunocomplejos, debido a la misma
infección viral.
Pero el daño clínico, el susto de la paciente y la confusión que genera esto en su
historial médico futuro son totalmente evitables.
Así que nada, pero nada de amoxicilina.
¿Y respecto a lo del baloncesto?
Suspensión absoluta y estricta.
Ya explicamos que el riesgo de rotura esplénica es crítico.
Hay que asustarlo un poquito con esto, ¿no?
Hay que ser muy claros.
Adicionalmente, se le debe advertir con total franqueza que si llega a sentir un
dolor abdominal agudo súbito o un dolor referido hacia el hombro izquierdo,
debe acudir de inmediato al servicio de urgencias.
Bien, entendido. Pero, ¿qué hay de la serología?
O sea, tenemos el diagnóstico clínico y hematológico súper amarrado.
¿Vale la pena pedir pruebas de Epstein-Barr o anticuerpos?
Sí, se solicitan anticuerpos, heterófilos o una serología específica.
Pero no porque necesitemos más probabilidad matemática para el manejo sintomático
de hoy.
Entonces, ¿para qué?
Porque tener una confirmación irrefutable de laboratorio consolida el cumplimiento
de ese consejo restrictivo a largo plazo sobre los deportes de contacto.
Es mucho más fácil que un joven deje de jugar si ve un papel con un positivo
confirmado.
Tiene todo el sentido clínico y humano.
Y un apunte metodológico importante que hace medsemiotics es que
la base de datos no documenta los LRs específicos de estas
serologías.
Se asumen como confirmatorias, pero todo el peso matemático que
desglosamos hoy recae en la semiología y en el frotis celular.
Correcto. Los números fuertes vienen de la clínica.
Y así llegamos al final de este caso, pero los queremos dejar con una última
pregunta socrática, un pensamiento provocador para quienes nos escuchan
y que deben llevarse al hospital mañana.
Una vuelta de tuerca.
Exacto. ¿Qué harían si, después de todo este
brillante andamiaje de razonamiento clínico y bayesiano, la serología
específica frente a Epstein-Barr resulta ser negativa la próxima semana?
Tómense un segundo para procesar ese escenario.
Porque la verdad es un escenario que te hiela la sangre.
Cambia radicalmente el tablero.
Todos los cálculos y umbrales que analizamos hoy asumen la premisa
de que estamos discriminando entre una mononucleosis infecciosa y otras
faringitis comunes.
¿Y si esa premisa se cae?
El mensaje crítico para quien está en la clínica es que un síndrome
mononucleósico impecable, pero con pruebas serológicas de Epstein-Barr
negativas, te obliga a reabrir el caso desde cero en ese mismo
instante.
Inmediatamente.
Si no es Epstein-Barr, ¿ese cuadro de fiebre prolongada,
ganglios, esplenomegalia y linfocitos atípicos exige
descartar una infección por citomegalovirus, buscar
toxoplasmosis o con una importancia abismal?
Tanto clínica como de salud pública.
Exactamente. Investigar una infección aguda por el virus de la inmunodeficiencia
humana.
Y ahí radica la verdadera lección de hoy.
Empezamos hablando de cómo las aguas del diagnóstico clínico son súper turbias
y cómo signos muy precisos, como una petequia en el paladar o
un porcentaje de células atípicas, nos sirven de mapa.
Pero ese mapa tiene bordes claros.
Tal cual. Y cuando el laboratorio te dice que estás fuera del territorio del
Epstein-Barr, el verdadero límite de la evidencia aparece frente a ti.
Es en ese preciso momento de incertidumbre donde la disposición del médico a
cuestionar sus propias conclusiones y a reabrir el diferencial se vuelve la
herramienta clínica más irreemplazable de todas.
Totalmente de acuerdo. Ha sido un placer sumergirnos en este caso contigo y con
todos los que nos escuchan.
El placer ha sido mío.
Nos vemos en el próximo caso.